By Robbie, I have bone spurs in my cervical spine with some narrowing between some of the vertebrae,
wouldn't be beneficial to run bone regeneration or bone spurs on the rife machine.
Yes, absolutely. That's the way really I want you guys to be thinking. Everybody,
this call has a rife machine. I think you should use the rife machine. It should be your first go too.
Even with heart issues, there's heart blockage programs, there's on your machine. Those are
good things to run. We've seen just some miracles using the rife machine for all sorts of weird
things. So that should be your first go too thing. Now how much is it going to help? I don't know.
Think of also running the accelerated healing program. It's in the normalizing frequency program.
That's a favorite of mine for any musculoskeletal issues. When having bone spurs in a cervical
spine with some narrowing between some of the vertebrae is, let's say, I was going to say it's
common, but I think it'd be more fair to say is that it's literally everybody has that at a certain
age. So don't be overly concerned about that. Anybody that's done any contact sports probably has
that going on by the time they're 40. Everybody else has some DJs called degenerative
disdisease and degenerative joint disease. That's called osteoarthritis, those bones first.
And it is, I would say, if you took a sampling of a hundred people off the street that had
absolutely no neck pain and took x-rays of them, I would say that 98% of them, if anybody's over
30 years old, I mentioned 98% of them, you'd have some of that going on. Now if it's causing more
symptom patterns, I would say go to a chiropractor and make sure that that chiropractor knows that you
have a history of cancer so that they're not doing heavy manual adjustments on you. My opinion,
anybody with cancer should be going to a chiropractor that does either a some gentle technique or
activator technique because you don't want to have a pathological fracture. So
and you can't see if there's metastasis to bone via an x-ray unless you already have over 50%
bone loss. You won't be able to see it on an x-ray. So don't trust that a chiropractor. So I took an
x-ray of you and everything looks good. Your bones look really good. So I'm going to do this manual.
Adjustment on you even though you have a history of you know breast cancer and you know we
there's no you didn't have haven't had a pet scan lately to show that there's metastasis so
we took an x-ray and you're safe to go no you're not safe to go. You'd have to have over 50%
loss of bone density in the bone for it to be visible on a plain view x-ray. So make sure that you go
to a chiropractor that's due to low force or a low force technique like activator.